vivre dans une capitale en guerre voici
kiev la place maïdan ces bâtiments
monumentaux la mairie diffuse même
l'hymne de la ville
kiev comme endormi et dans laquelle les
boutiques sont fermées le bus à
touristes égarés dans le silence le
magasin de lingerie à déshabiller ses
mannequins dans les rues peu de voitures
et peu de passants
il ya un bus toutes les heures ou même
toutes les deux heures
et il ne s'agit pas de le rater
dans chaque quartier une supérette
encore ouverte mais les rayons sont de
plus en plus vides
je voulais de la viande fraîche pour
cuisiner un peu
et alors
bah non
à la fin c'est le rayon viande donc
entièrement vide en revanche il ya de la
viande séchée
quelques produits frais beaucoup de
conserve le café le thé les biscuits ne
manquent pas mais les camions n'arrivent
plus jusqu'ici
c'est tout ce qui nous reste tout est en
rayon on ne nous livre aucune
marchandise rien du tout
s'il y a un siège il faudra compter sur
ses stocks en ville la poste ouvre
quelques heures par jour pour les
retraités qui viennent retirer leur
pension les cabinets médicaux en ville
ont fermé alors comment fait-on pour se
soigner
mon mari hier il a une rage de dents
mais on a réussi à trouver quelqu'un qui
lui a donné rendez vous à un endroit et
la soigner gratuitement
kiev où quelques images vous rappelle
qu'il y a quinze jours la vie y était
encore douce